the beverage industry
is one of the world's top consumers of
water coca-cola says it replaces
every drop that it uses but a cbs news
investigation raises questions about
how to evaluate that promise jonathan
vigliotti recently visited a city in
southern mexico where coca-cola
is everywhere jonathan good morning tony
good morning to you the city of san
cristobal's struggle to get clean
drinking water was profiled by the new
york times in 2018
many people said the water started
disappearing when the coca-cola bottling
plant began operations decades earlier
coca-cola says it has exceeded its
expectations for water security in
mexico for several years
but we discovered something different
when we recently visited
and took our findings back to the
company
the highlands of chiapas in southern
mexico are rugged
and remote but when we arrived we saw
signs
of america everywhere
people here are among the biggest
consumers of coca-cola
in the world one study found three
percent of babies
and 16 percent of toddlers in chiapas
drink soda i'd be drinking coca-cola
from a plastic bag
while coke doesn't flow from the taps
critics say the coke bottling plant in
san cristobal de las casas
consumes much of the town's drinking
water to make soda
shop after shop here advertises
coca-cola but the one thing
this neighborhood does not have is
running water residents of this
neighborhood
invited us to see what's left in their
municipal water tanks
[Music]
jose is telling me that these three
tanks are the main source of water for
this community
can you open the lid
no water juan semanas synagogues
data from coca-cola shows 39 of the
company's global production was
generated in high
or extremely high water stressed regions
and some of those products end up on
american store shelves
we reached out to coca-cola they
declined to speak on camera
but told us in a statement they met and
exceeded their replenishment goals
for five years in mexico so sylvia is
showing us how she gets water for her
house
sylvia perez-mendez relies on rainwater
seeing este agua without this water
tiene
agua potable in la casa no you wouldn't
have
any drinking water without this water in
the house no and with climate change
impacting rainfall sylvia's reserves are
running low
it's sad we can't bathe we can't clean
we can't drink water she says
sylvia is part of a growing group of
residents calling on coca-cola and the
mexican government to protect their
water supply
how many of you struggle to get water
every week
every day coca-cola takes the water cbs
news has found the san cristobal
bottling plant
is permitted by the government to
extract around 110 million gallons of
water
each year even as rainfall has declined
and a growing population has moved into
protected wetlands
last year the local government requested
the federal water utility
revoke the bottling plant's water
license but was denied
the utility said in a statement the
plant draws water from wells that are
deep
underground and do not affect the local
water supply
coca-cola's influence in the region
began in the 1960s with marketing that
had
religious undertones
[Music]
and an indigenous churches across
southern mexico
we found it used during prayers
coke also helps fuel the economy
employing 358 people at the bottling
plant
and supporting hundreds of shops that
sell its product
but doctors say this financial lifeline
for many
may also be making people sick dr marcos
arana
researches diabetes in the region we
know that in
adults over 40 years of age it's over
35 percent over 35 percent
have diabetes arana says without easy
access to water
people are primarily drinking coke
specifically addressing our findings in
chiapas coca-cola said we recognize the
challenges the san cristobal community
faces
and that is why we've been working for
nearly a decade to provide community
water tanks
rooftop water collectors and water
conservation projects
[Applause]
sylvia perez-mendez claims her community
has not received
any of that help she will continue her
fight for more water she says
until she sees real change and coca-cola
says going forward
it is setting specific context-based
targets
that seek to create water security
including planting hundreds of thousands
of trees in the region
regarding potential health impacts
coca-cola says it is continuing to
reformulate its products in mexico
to further reduce overall sugar
consumption anthony
jonathan thank you yeah one thing is
clear coca-cola should not be replacing
water